elections the only excuse for a grown
man to kiss a stranger's baby and not
have the cops court as you may know
there was an important election coming
up we're just about a year away from
when American voters will head to the
polls and choose the next president of
the United States can Ben Carson
actually win the Republican nomination
can Bernie Sanders take Iowa and New
Hampshire the biggest question right now
is will Vice President Joe Biden throw
his hat in the ring will Al Gore run for
president no he won't
and who gives a it's still a year
from now by the time it's done the 2016
election will have lasted the entire
lifespan of a hamster from birth all the
way to popsicle stick grave we should
not be talking about the 2016 race when
America has very important elections
taking place this Tuesday in just two
days
there are gubernatorial and all
legislative elections taking place in
these four states and many other people
will be voting in local elections or on
important referenda like Washington
State initiative 1401 which would
prohibit people from selling buying
trading or distributing parts of
elephants rhinoceroses tigers cheetahs
and pangolins and if you're wondering
what a Pangolin is lets me show you
the Pangolin is not very ferocious it
doesn't even have teeth
and it's not very fast in fact it has to
wobble on a time legs and tail
what is that ridiculous mess
it looks like the result of a
Stegosaurus making love to an artichoke
look if you're thinking right now what I
don't live in one of those four states
and I'm not a Pangolin why should I give
a
well let me tell you there are American
lives at stake here because a number of
these elections could determine whether
hundreds of thousands of people remain
in or even fall into what's known as the
Medicaid gap and I know that sounds like
a terrible clothing chain where you can
buy cocky hospital gowns sold by
children in India but amazingly it's
even worse than that meet Kathy Owen a
Texas woman who can't afford insurance
has a family history of colon cancer and
is desperately saving up for a
colonoscopy $8,000 stands between me and
maybe another 20 years of my life if I
have colon cancer but I find myself now
at 53 with grown kids and serious need
of help hard to ask for but absolutely
necessary that's just terrible
$8,000 should not be the difference
between living or dying it should be the
difference between buying this
authenticated bass guitar signed by Paul
McCartney and this baseball supposedly
signed by Kanye West and by the way why
does that object exist it's Kanye West
interrupting baseball games now imma let
you finish this pitch but my signature
is the greatest signature of all time of
all time look if your instinct is wasn't
Obamacare supposed to solve this kind of
problem well yes you're right it was to
oversimplify things just a bit the idea
was under Obamacare people without
insurance will be split into two groups
those who made upwards of 138 percent of
the poverty line would be eligible to
buy insurance with subsidies up to a
certain point and as for the poorest
Americans Medicaid which is previously
generally applied to children their
parents
disabled would have been expanded to
include everyone else at which point
with everyone insured America is
supposed to go outside brush the dead
leaves off the trampoline and celebrate
with a backflip and a broken tibia the
Supreme Court even famously upheld
Obamacare in 2012 what you may not
remember is that even that very day
there were hints it may not have been an
unequivocal victory John Roberts sided
with the four liberal justices voting
five to four to uphold nearly all of
President Obama's health-care law and
there's the problem because nearly all
is not a reassuring statement health
care is like a pair of gym shorts even
if it covers nearly all of what it's
supposed to you're still left with some
problematic gaps and terrible things can
happen let me explain the Supreme Court
struck down the part of the law which
enabled the government to force States
to expand Medicaid which meant states
could choose to reject the expansion
even though that that would be an odd
decision under the law the federal
government would pay a hundred percent
of the cost for the first three years
eventually decreasing to 90 percent and
I can't think of anything I would not
buy if I only had to pay ten percent of
the price Fred Claus on DVD I mean no
thank you but yes I'll take it Vince
borne is always good for 49 cents worth
of yucks basically for the relatively
little of their own money states could
cover all their poorest citizens it was
an exceptionally favorable deal but
guess what many states chose to do Texas
will not be participating in Medicaid
expansion they're working hard to change
the American dream into the European
nightmare this system we call Obamacare
that we now see is going to be a train
wreck and I do not want the name of
Mississippi emblazoned across that train
when it leaves the tracks
would you consider expanding a broken
system of course not
of course not it's like a drug dealer
you give them your first hit free and
then they're hooked for years and years
yeah except in this instance that drug
addict has cancer the drug being pushed
is chemo and the corner boys have seven
years of med school
20 states have so far declined to expand
Medicaid leaving over 3 million people
in the Medicaid gap people in the
illogical situation of not making enough
money to receive government assistance
just listen to LaShawn B hoard diabetic
who at one point was forced to reuse
needles to save money I don't make
enough money to get the insurance
through federal government and then I
made two months to get Medicaid and I
cannot afford the insurance that's
offered at my job so um I'm just hanging
in the air it's hard to explain how
disappointing it is ok the word
disappointing does not quite cover it's
disappointing
is your child dropping out of college to
be a street mime Gerald your mother's
devastated do not pretend you can't hear
me inside that glass box I know you can
hear me Gerald this kind of situation is
not disappointing it's tragic the
frequent argument for states refusing
the expansion is they couldn't bear the
increased cost although it is worth
noting that to their credit even
fiscally conservative Republican
governors like Jan Brewer chris Christie
Mike Pence and John Kasich did expand
Medicaid in their states despite being
firm opponents of Obamacare I don't
support Obamacare I want to repeal it
that I did expand Medicaid because I was
able to bring Ohio money back home to
treat the mentally ill the drug addicted
and to help the working poor get health
care because you opposed Obamacare
doesn't mean when you have an
opportunity to bring these 14 billion
dollars of Ohio money back to Ohio
that's not Obamacare that's Medicaid you
know what good for him good for him
although it's a bit weird when accepting
billions of dollars to give health care
to poor people is somehow a brave and
noble stand when all Kasich technically
did was see a dump truck full of money
backing into his driveway and just not
say stop
all of which brings us back to Tuesday's
elections because in these three states
they could determine the fate of
Medicaid expansion so let's start with
Mississippi there incumbent governor
phil Bryant opposes the expansion the
good news is his opponent has promised
if elected he'll expand it the bad news
is his opponent is this guy political
experts in Mississippi were stumped when
the long-haul trucker who ran no
campaign to speak of and who was
essentially unknown outside his own home
was elected as the Democratic nominee to
be governor
spent how much in this race maybe 50 $60
50 $60 in the whole campaign no signs in
the yard no bumper stickers no anything
Gray's run for the nomination was so
low-key he forgot to mention it to his
own mother I called him an active Robert
you burn it for governor and I was like
now he would have told us and she's like
no it's him holy girl there is a
difference between running a low-key
campaign and not having name recognition
within your own family and if you're
wondering how on earth he got that
nomination well some people have a
theory some think it's simply because
Gray's name was the first on the ballot
others say it's because he has a
traditional man's name he is a male and
this is Mississippi oh he is a male and
this is Mississippi it's depressing when
that's all you have to say and everyone
understands it was an attractive goat
and this is West Virginia I get it I get
it I don't need any more details we're
on the same page it's pretty clear at
this point Robert gray is not going to
be the next governor of Mississippi so
let's move on to Virginia where the
obstacle to Medicaid expansion is their
state legislature for anything to happen
Democrats would first have to gain two
senate seats and one of the Senate's
leading opponents of expansion is dick
black whose name yes
sounds like a category heading in an
adult bookstore but believe me he's
considerably less fun than his name
suggests for instance he won't sent a
thank you letter to Bashar al Assad
commending him for his extraordinary
gallantry in his war against terrorists
a letter Assad posted to his face
page which I'd say was the worst thing
he'd ever posted on social media if it
weren't for this genuine Instagram photo
of his windshield on a rainy day which
is sad whassat actually tagged hashtag
rain
hashtag morning hashtag photo of the day
hashtag best of the day hashtag
instigate hashtag Syrian presence and
since he Assad abuses hashtags almost as
much as he abuses the Syrian people and
by the way Bashar al-assad is not alone
in getting surprising envelopes from
dick black years ago when he was in the
House of Delegates and sponsoring an
anti-abortion measure he left envelopes
on Senators desks with little plastic
pink fetuses inside
well that is revolting it almost makes
you mr. dick black who was running in
Virginia was legendary according this
dick black I'm sure he could find a
great campaign song from his actual
album a taste of dick black a taste of
dick black now is that relevant to what
we were talking about absolutely not but
you cannot deny it's a nice palate
cleanser after you just heard the phrase
plastic fetuses but perhaps the most
striking election this year is in
Kentucky where they did expand Medicaid
and by all accounts it has worked
brilliantly Kentucky has seen the
nation's steepest drop in the rate of
uninsured residents only an idiot would
try to undo that which brings me to
gubernatorial candidate Matt Bevin he
has been accused of wanting to end the
expansion and kick people off Medicaid
something he denies you're hearing
things that I'm supposedly saying which
in fact I've never said I've never said
I'm gonna kick people off of Medicaid it
all right okay fine you never said that
well I presume that means that this
footage does not exist the fact that we
have one out of four people in this
state on Medicaid is unsustainable it's
unaffordable the fewer governor you
would undo his executive order to fan
Medicaid absolutely no question about I
would reverse that immediately the only
rational explanation is that Matt Bevin
has cloned himself and his clone bats
mevin is even stupider than he is and
what what makes his opposition to
government assistance is especially hard
to take is that he heads up a family
bail making business whose connecticut
factory sadly burned down a few years
ago so what did this staunch small
government free-market advocate do owner
Matthew Bevin vows to rebuild and he may
be getting some help senator Blumenthal
vows to explore EPA grants for clean up
possible small business loans and
potential resources from FEMA and other
federal agencies your kind offer to
basically form Team Belltown is critical
now to be fair team Belltown did not
receive federal assistance Bevin did
however get a hundred thousand dollar
state grant to reopen his Factory
so if Matt Bevin ends up winning I
presume he'll give you health care as
long as you cover yourself in bells and
set yourself on fire but the real irony
here is that Bevin did not have
insurance to cover the fire because he
claimed no company would insure the
buildings for a price that made sense
that's right because the cost of
insurance was too high he needed to turn
to the government for help and quite
frankly Matt Bevin that should ring a
bell
and yet and
after broke now his race is considered a
toss-up
he could win just like a dick black
could win and just like Robert gray
definitely once so on Tuesday even if
you don't live in a state holding an
election spare a thought for the people
who do because the results may
ultimately affect the health of half a
million people and of course one
ridiculous looking animal